why has this pretty likable Tik tocker
suddenly had his entire audience turn on
him me these just are good and he has so
many likes mentioned kby went from
making six or seven videos per day to
basically never
posting by the grace of Allah subhah the
response has been overwhelming to say
the very least alhamdulillah we've had
social media personalities and respected
Scholars sh from many parts of the
Muslim world promoting the cause we have
raised almost 1.4 million alhamdulillah
and we haven't been sitting idy waiting
to hit our Target of 2 million we have
fully purchased four properties in
London transferred their ownership to
the W after the help of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala none of this would be possible
without your support so we thank you
once again this is our update to
yourselves we encourage you to stay
tuned for more updates now that the work
alhamdulillah is truly underway
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah so this
was a video was shown to me by zishan
about please tell me his name kabami
yeah I would have changed my name bro
that's a why are you cussing him no it's
a difficult name to pronounce you don't
even use your real name exactly DA's not
written on your passport yes exactly
imagine it was called ER da kich oh
bloody so anyways Jo ald so this is a
video of talking about his downfall or
something and I don't even know if it's
actually a down it just looks like
there's a lot of hate but there's a few
things that we need to take from this
because the thing is it seems like you
know um he stopped posting videos Etc so
we're going to find out why but it's
really important when it comes to this
stuff because we're talking about what
Allah subhana wa Tal's willed um and
when people give you hate for reasons uh
which shows you about like jealousy and
envy which is really really important um
to discuss because it's one of the main
issues that we have even in the public
sphere even with some people like with
us when it comes to us YouTubers uh we
get this kind of hate as well but we'll
come to that in so um let's just react
to some of the parts in and see what's
going on with this brother kab kab kabi
kab Lami kabami Lam's comment section
has gotten pretty brutal fall off is
crazy your time is over bro put the
fries in the bag all of which have
appeared in just the last few months why
has this pretty likable Tik tocker
suddenly had his entire audience turn on
him well judging by another comment
reading why did we make him the most
followed person on Tik Tok people are
starting to think that he doesn't really
deserve it he gained 162 million
followers by repeating a pretty simple
formula find ridiculous videos of people
exerting too much effort on the most
basic tasks then show how to do it in a
much easier way can't believe he got
that big just from reacting to humans
being dumb even kab Lami himself stated
my videos are simple and easy but
achieving a point of Simplicity was
actually very difficult he gained just
nine views and only two followers during
his first month on Tik Tok which only
grew to 4,300 after posting a crazy
amount of volume I was posting like six
or seven video a day although this
worked unbelievably well as he began to
celebrate Milestone after Milestone
300,000 400,000 600,000 whilst his
ability to silently clown on others only
got better and better he began taking
already viral videos and had an
unexpected Stitch to make them even
funnier leading to his first properly
viral video roasting a girl for her
non-existent
haircut K's respect from the audience
was building higher and higher leading
to a further 60 million views after
roasting another Tik tocker for his
strange shaving video
this then doubled to 130 million when he
joke about a factory worker eating his
chocolates however it' be this video
here that changed his life
forever mocking the stupid life hack
gained him 250 million views repeated in
another four videos which followed a
similar premise celebrated a million
followers on the 22nd of February which
by the 23rd of May had grown to 50
million although with somebody calling
this a big L for Tik Tok there were
people who weren't happy with kabi Lam's
Fame judging by 46.2 million followers
For What and 8.8 million likes for what
people thought there was too much reward
for too little efforts which can often
turn into a person becoming hated main
joke is that kby gained over 100 million
followers by doing nothing on the
unpopular opinion subreddits when user
wrote kab Lami is boring not funny
predictable low effort and famous just
because he uses other people's content
90% of his Tik toks are low effort he
has a few quality bits but that's it he
shouldn't deserve the recognition he's
got right now I really have nothing
against the guy just that there are some
people people who put real efforts and
can't get through and I don't think
that's fair others didn't like him
simply because they thought he wasn't
funny it hurts me cuz these just aren't
good and he has so many likes after he
became the most followed on Tik Tok ever
since he passed Charlie he's not been on
my fyp also being noticed by Noah Glen
Carter cuz he's basically done nothing
since becoming number one like he never
even made a video celebrating or
acknowledging that he was now the number
one most followed Tik tocker and since
becoming number one he's posted once
maybe twice a week as mentioned kabi
went from making six or seven videos per
day to basically never posting he
instead began to State I want to make
films this is my main objective I've
wanted to make movies since I was a
almost implying he was better than his
Tik Tok audience when he did post a
video it was often just an ad kabby did
promotions for Airbnb Hugo Boss even
Facebook and by disrespecting his
audience with loads of different ads the
audience would also lose respect for him
he used to be so famous how did bro get
okay there's a lot of things to dissect
boy but um I mean look this this disease
um of jealousy and envy these are these
are things that we all have internally
there's good type of jealousy and
there's bad bad type of jealousy the
good type is that you want the same what
the another person has it could be
friend it can be your neighbor it can be
your family member you want the same
thing you're like what you've blessed
with this person if it's good for me
bless me with it as well but the bad
type of envy and jealousy is that you
you hate the fact that that person has
why is this uh so harmful because this
is what done because you want them to
lose what they have and for you to gain
it exactly and that is dangerous it's
like what do you get out of losing that
and not only that when you do that who
is the one who blessed them with that
and if it is a Blessing by the because
it it's subjective of what is a blessing
if just because somebody drives a ni
kind has a house what is your how have
you determined that to be a good thing
that could be a bad thing do you get
what I'm trying to say but the issue is
what you have a problem with that's a
very good point I recently I just heard
a scholar I think exemplified the point
of s
who who Lo who lost his eyesight later
on in his age and his duas would be
accepted so people would come and
request them for duas exactly and
somebody asked him once that look you
make duas for other people how comes you
don't make du for yourself and your
eyesight and he said and I'm obviously
I'm going to butcher it um but if I was
to paraphrase he was saying something
like well this is what Allah has decreed
and who am I to say and ask for
something else that is not the decree of
Allah it's as if I'm saying that what
I'm asking is better than the decree of
Allah so that's what their IM was that
and this is exactly the point that when
you see somebody with something that's
something that Allah decreed for that
person good or bad but for you to wish
that that person didn't have it it's as
if you have an issue with the decree of
Allah that's where it boils down to
because there was one creator that
saying how is it that he does I mean
where he are struggling so hard what's
your point what is your point I don't
understand we get this sometimes like
some from people of knowledge like oh I
went to Medina and I done this Etc how
comes I don't have this kind of
following how comes and we don't go to
certain details but the with certain
Brothers around us who've told the
stories I mean some brothers in the
other parts of the world are very very
direct with this they're jealous they
don't even hide it literally they come
to individuals I don't want to go detail
and tell them to their face how jealous
they are of them and Subhan Allah the
the point is what number one it shows
you brother and sisters that when it
comes to issue it's the of Allah what
Allah subh has decreed for whoever it is
is going to happen and another thing
that I noticed towards the end of the
video it talks about when he reached and
beat that other in Tik tocker he stopped
posting if you've noticed uh ice and
fury when he hit his Peak and he became
the champion of World Champ wherever he
said he went to depression you know what
that shows you AI it shows that Subhan
Allah we have to as human beings always
have to be in a type of struggle and
striving until we die because otherwise
bro if you have everything in the world
you genuinely get depressed we human
beings we lack new targets new things
that we want to do and when we reach
like for example if you or me was to
become the top watch YouTuber in the
world it's like okay what next do you
get it it really hits you so some people
when when you want that's why we say you
know you might love something which is
bad for you and you might hate something
which is good for you so we need to
understand the Dynamics of Allah subhana
deals with that's why you mentioned the
sahaba he understood his relationship
with Allah he didn't say oh Allah hates
me that's why he took my eyes or Allah
hates me that's why I have a disease you
don't know that's why when you look at
other people don't make a Dua we had
this issue four or five years ago of a
specific couple where people were making
Dua oh I wish my husband was like that
oh I wish I had a wife like that and
then we knew their reality and like I
said before maybe they've repented
they're probably better than us but the
point is what you was making a Dua for
Destruction without knowing based on
your empirism which is that observing
something with your eyes and thinking oh
that's good you get what I'm trying to
say and this is where we need to be
careful and to me this shows that what
Allah has weighed you know Allah says in
the Quran that we have everything has a
is been weighed it has it portion that's
what it is you cannot run away from it
you know what Allah subhana has decreed
is going to happen and you're going to
get hate you bound to you're bound to
get this the creator of this video it
seemed like I mean I was shaking my head
because it was the way he was trying to
spin some of these things okay he's
become the most followed Tik tocker but
now suddenly he needs to continue
posting on Tik Tok who why is why is
that the criteria why does he have to
continue posting on Tik Tok I mean Tik
Tok we know it's a it's a social media
platform that supposed to push you to do
other more lucrative things we know even
the monetization on Tik Tok is not great
so what do you expect him to do just
because he's now the most followed Tik
tocker he has to now stay on Tik Tok and
if he doesn't he's let his fans down and
it's disrespectful to him that he's
doing adverts well this is the most you
know what Dil is this I mean he's
posting less he's getting more
opportunities that's absolutely fine
he's allowed to do that in fact his
going after his other dreams and I saw
one clip of somebody saying that you
know when you got grass and a tree grow
growing but a tree when it grows it
totally leaves the grass behind so this
is what it is and some people give the
example certain rappers say you know we
started off in the ghetto but people
saying oh we're letting the side down no
we've outgrown the ghetto we've moved
out we don't have to stick with it for
the rest of our lives so just because a
person's on Tik Tok doesn't mean they
have to stay on Tik Tok forever and
those people saying oh I don't find him
funny you don't find a lot of people
funny why are you making a video about
kabami oh because you by making a video
on him you're going to attain more
relevance so again it's selective hate
as well you don't find him funny well
comedy is subjective yeah so and you're
saying oh why is he getting so many
likes because other people find him
funny yeah yeah and he's found this
Niche there are loads of such videos
there there's one Auntie here in the UK
all she does anytime a bus is going past
she just puts a camera up and she films
herself and then a bus going past and
she's become famous just for doing that
and it's it's a it's a unique video and
she's become famous amongst the people
that's unique and and that's why I'm
saying that if whatever in it like
whatever you do certain people will do
like certain people this is another
question people have that oh what if
somebody doesn't accept Islam and you
know they you know and they pass away
and they go to the Hellfire and this and
that one of our responses is they get um
they get their reward in this world yeah
yeah yeah for whatever they do they get
and if they didn't know about Islam
they'll be judged on the day of judgment
and if they didn't know about Islam they
would end up in the Hellfire and that is
what Allah Allah is the most trust and
I'll just end on this which which I'm so
sorry I your name uh but B you heard it
so many times yeah I know I know but so
with him he said that look I don't care
about people I look at the hearts Etc
yeah that's why you know Allah says you
know have you seen the one who has
multiple Masters because if you think
about it look at the entitlement and the
expectation they have of him why coming
off Tik top why you doing this no we
don't find it funny now you need to do
this multiple Masters meaning if he was
to follow the roote of trying to please
his audience he would be unhappy and
they would never be happy that's why it
is important to even if means
displeasing the create creation over uh
the pleasure of the Creator brother and
sisters yeah if you try to attain
people's never me and you get hate bro I
get hate hijab gets hate we all get hate
yes and as long as we know the purpose
is what I am insh doing this for this
reason I don't care about your praises
and your dispraise bro because now
you're praising me in 3 weeks time if I
do something wrong you're going to start
attacking me it's a known Trend and
Allah is teaching us a lesson with all
of these things when it comes from our
wives our parents our children our
family our friends Allah always shows
you that the only one that is truly
there for you is Allah nobody else and
if we put this as a priority this
doesn't mean we neglect our friends Etc
no or or family members but if we put
Allah first you will never be
disappointed so that's all I want to say
in and like I said before help the
brother in obviously he's he's a Muslim
you know alhamd as long put is first and
those things permissible ET there's
nothing wrong with and he's fine I still
see him Instagram in that's what we want
to say in what Allah has decreed don't
be jealous don't be envious ask Allah
subhana to give you the same as other
person inah and don't fall into the
Sunnah of Shan thank you touched your
nose with that and now suddenly you oh
so our friendship hasn't reached that
level yet
[Laughter]